[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum welcome everyone thank
you for listening thank you for taking
the time and uh we all have a busy
schedule so the fact that you're
listening to this podcast is it makes me
happy there's so many podcasts out there
Ryan so many thanks covid yeah if covet
hit and everybody every celebrity
decided to get a
get a podcast you had it first we all
know yeah well yeah yeah you know at
least my the my loyal listeners have
stuck by me and I appreciate that my
lovely patrons
um keep the show going patreon.comcity
if you want to become a patron uh
there's tons of perks they send you
boxes of merch and little notes and
there's tons of stuff and go to the
inside of you online store if you like
and get some cool merch some small Bill
stuff there's ship Keys sign Lexus
script signed all that but more
importantly
Ryan's breaking [__]
um but the inside of your handles Ryan
what are they outside of your pod on
Twitter inside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook that's right so
please uh support the podcast write a
review subscribe
um these things are really important
keep the podcast going if you're here
for Jim Gaffigan hopefully you'll like
it enough to give us another shot it's
more about talking to people real people
real conversations and uh understanding
human nature mental health all that
along with career and just real stuff we
try to keep it real here on this podcast
so
um also just a reminder that uh Tom and
I will be doing a lot of cons this year
as of now so make sure you look at our
schedule or keep track at the Michael
Rosenbaum on Instagram and at Michael
Rosenbaum on Twitter because we'll we'll
be uh posting
um
about different things we have uh
Whatchamacallit Atlanta March fourth and
5th we're doing a Smallville night so if
you're near Atlanta you want to come see
the show and some autographs and
pictures and have a great time with us
we'd love to have you and um my band uh
sunspan go to sunspin.com for Merch uh
also Sun spin on Spotify or anywhere you
hear your music our new album never is
what it is is out there we're really
proud of it I hope hopefully you'll give
it a listen I really think you're gonna
like it so let me know what you think
and we do a lot of performances at stage
it so there's that Ryan what are you
doing you busy this
here you're here did a lot of podcasts
this week both of them yeah doing the
talk fill podcast doing this podcast
it's um you know what's funny there's a
couple of my celebrity friends that are
actually calling me about like hey could
maybe we do a podcast under your
umbrella like uh you know like maybe I
know you know a lot about I'm like uh I
don't I'll talk to Bryce about that
stuff
but I was thinking about it'd be kind of
cool if like you know we sort of like
started producing other podcasts on the
side hiring different people to do those
things you know
um and just you know help them sort of
navigate and what you're supposed to do
what you can do how you can get people
to listen and you know what makes it
appealing and the equipment you need and
the commitment you need I think the
number one thing people don't realize is
the commitment you you you're making a
commitment not only to this project but
to your to your listeners you can't just
go oh I'll do one when I feel like it no
they they'll go away they want somebody
they could hear every week that might
give them a little insight into
something and um or have good
conversations so I think that they don't
realize there's a lot of work that goes
with it a lot of these actors are like
you know I'm doing a movie and this and
you know I'm gonna do a little podcast
on the side well you better commit to it
because listeners will not stick around
if you don't
um so there you go great guest today I
know you love this guy I like him um
he's um he's a he's a great guy he's a
great conversation great Storyteller
great comedian he's had a lot of
specials he's got this new movie
linoleum which I thought was really cool
and you know I said this in the
interview to him but
he
there's something really interesting
about him as a character and when I
watched him play this role Cameron from
this movie The linoleum I was I was like
really impressed like this this is I
could definitely see him I wouldn't be
shocked they're like and a nomination
for Academy Award Go I mean sometime
down the line because I think he has
that ability and um
passion
he does a lot of things and I think
you're going to really enjoy this one
and we talk about about everything so
get your pants on let's get inside of
Jim Gaffigan it's my
[Music]
Palm
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience this has been a long time
coming Mr Gaffigan right I mean yeah we
both had that show on TV Land with very
similar uh outcomes you left the show
and I got canceled so similar well what
I don't even know what is yeah that was
TV Land was going to
I mean it was kind of
stream like before they thought that
it's like when Viacom thought they had a
shot right
yeah that's exactly right
oh my God we're in complete denial
they're like we're Viacom we had
Nickelodeon and MTV we couldn't do
anything and then and then it didn't
work out I remember they called me and
they said hey we like your show it just
it's not right for us
and I'm like well it's the end of this
we just finished our second season
you're just figuring that out now and
all right okay well that's the way it
rolls
yeah I mean by the way we're in a very
I mean I don't want to sound naive but
it's I mean I feel like television or
traditional television cable or whatever
is in a weird place now too right mm-hmm
I think about this the power that AMC
had
oh yeah they were they were pushing out
really quality shows and they were The
Walking Dead and the they were like the
HBO of yesteryear yeah Mad Men they had
that
um
uh you know they just you know they
everything they touched was gold
and now it's like but I don't know now
now I feel like this I I really wish I
understood it but I'm not that
interested I just want to like I just
want to act so I'm kind of like just
when can I do that well you do that too
much I think I'm looking at your stuff
and I'm just like holy it's just like I
remember
I was telling your publicist uh
that I remember we were doing like
Carson Daly 15 years ago and you were
doing stand-up and I was a guest and I
just remember I remember saying I go is
anyone watching you're like well yeah
maybe by the way if uh if one of those
late night show if today's late night
shows had the ratings that Carson had
then yeah they'd be huge now yeah
because there's so many streaming
platforms and it's great for but to me
it's like I go to uh I go to a
restaurant tell me how you feel about
this I go to a restaurant and I like
chicken steak
I like not I don't want tons of stuff
like a you know like the old uh
what's the deli the Famous Deli green
not green blasts the uh where the
bowling alley was in Studio City
Jerry's Deli but they have this huge
menu and it just confused me and so I
feel like
somebody have you seen this show I'm
like uh no have you seen this show it's
on uh Tulu Tulu what the hell's to Hulu
I don't know what to watch
yeah there is
I I mean we are I mean this might not be
interesting but we are obviously paying
for Apple Plus or whatever yeah and
we have it on our our uh on our screens
but like when I travel I'm watching
things on my iPad I don't have
Apple TV
on my iPad so when I watch shows
like I loved fleischmann's in trouble
which is on some streaming platform that
I have but like I don't have
I don't have Apple TV on my iPad so I
haven't seen Severance I haven't either
and I haven't downloaded
and I haven't done the Paramount plus so
like there's certain things I haven't
seen
yeah I mean there's a lot of things so
it's probably good for actors because
there's more shows out there to audition
for but then you can start thinking well
what what's the platform I have the best
chance of actually being seen on
well and by the way which brings us back
to
the TV Lane thing the problem with TV
Land is
at that point
I remember encountering this people were
like I've never watched TV Land so I'm
never gonna go and find that channel
right
whereas it used to be
I think there was somebody that said
that
the reason that today show was so
successful initially is because people
had watched The Tonight Show and they
turned off their TV and when they turned
it back on it was on NBC and so they
were watching The Today Show right isn't
that amazing it's amazing like habit is
a really important thing do you like it
do you like all these options do you
like all these streaming how do you feel
about it no I think I I think I did a
tweet where I was like they should uh
gather all the streaming platforms
together and call them cable you know
what I mean it's just
because there's so many I I usually go I
hear about something and I I go oh I
have to so I subscribe I watch the show
and then I cancel
that's smart that's the only thing I
wonder why she'll call me cost me 9.99
um look you know what's crazy about this
I've I've known you for a long time I
think we've known each other we've been
the same Circle I love Michael Ian Black
you put him in all your things and um uh
we're mutual friends with Jason Patrick
he's a very close friend of mine which
I'll talk in a minute but I started like
why because everybody I think knows you
for the most part is being this hugely
successful author and stand-up comedian
you know that's what you know funny guy
he's this
and I started going through [__] and my
engineer here Ryan and I was just like
and I watched linoleum
and I was just I was my jaw dropped I'm
like
you know he goes maybe this is why they
always say comedians are the best actors
dramatic actors because I watched the
trailer which I now have to see of being
frank which looks hilarious but like
linoleum
I don't even recognize you and it took
me forever to go is that is he playing
that guy too no he's got a different
voice he he looks completely different I
was baffled by it
oh well thanks yes well you know you
know this is the perception industry
right
and so
I you know and I'm sure that like you
were
forever trying to like not be Lex Luthor
right so you're you know the perception
thing is
there is uh so like look I like stand-up
comedy I mean I love stand-up comedy I
love comedy and all that but like
for me it's about what's
creatively fulfilling and so
um the more complex a role usually in an
indie usually in a drama is more
fulfilling acting and so I'd rather do
that than
you know I mean I'd have fun on a uh
working on a comedy you know but it's
not as fulfilling probably as playing uh
you know a guy who lives in snake
healing you know I did this movie them
that follow that you know like that's
you know like there's kind of the the
minutia of dramatic roles that are
it's uh it's more fulfilling I think
yeah you know I mean comedy's fun but
like
uh and maybe because I get to do stand
up that I don't feel the need to kind of
um
go go into that thing but it's you know
so I'm perceived as a comedian and then
I've ever whenever I do a movie and then
there's a press afterwards it's it's
always like people don't realize that
I've been doing uh dramas for a while
because none of them are that successful
so it's like but it's all right it's you
know there's got to be a narrative to
everything yeah I think they do it's I
said to Ryan I said there's no debt I
could totally see you getting nominated
for an Oscar sometime I I just genuinely
not because I'm not blowing smoke it's
just because
I just don't when people see it it's
like you're you're just so different
which is great the juxtaposition of
seeing you doing comedy and being the
funny guy and very personal and then
playing this quirky character from a
little place in Ohio and so you know and
look linoleum
is screening right now at the Palm
Springs International Fest it was in
South by Southwest it's one Awards Tony
Shalhoub the whole cast is great
um
it's it's just what I was talking to
publicist again I was like you know it's
touching it's mysterious it's thought
provoking uh at the end it brought me to
tears for some reason because I don't
want to say anything but like the old
man with the you know I don't want to
give it away but like just the whole
thing and then putting it together I was
like did I get this right is this what I
this is what I my interpretation was and
she was like yeah that's that's right
and I came gave myself a pat on the back
but um it deals with issues of identity
and memory and achievement but deals
with hope as sad as it can be at times
and uh you know I just I really and I
watched it this morning dude and getting
me to watch anything yeah I'm [__]
like so I was like I really urge people
to go see linoleum when it comes out in
selected theaters and whenever do you
have any idea when that's going to be or
right now we'll just post that I think
it's in uh end of February
right but it is it's it's
linoleum is unique
and other things that I've uh from other
things that I've worked with that
it is one of those movies that like the
last 10 minutes
people you know people often cry because
it's like you're caught off guard but
also it's one of
you know creative people we love
discussing and you don't want to agree
with everyone but like it's great
because it's one of those movies that
presents questions and people take
different things some people say it's
about ambition some people say it's
about memory some people say I think
it's like a love story I think it's like
you know we we we go through life and
and particularly creative people I think
we're like you know
we're caught in like okay you know I if
I can just get this job if I can if I
can achieve this thing and you know and
you and I we both had some success and
eventually you have to
kind of
evaluate what is the measure of success
is it creative fulfillment is it
obviously it's Human Relationships you
know I mean like so like if you're in a
successful relationship and it doesn't
even matter if that relationship ends
like that's pretty that's in some ways
that's pretty fantastic right like the
ups and downs and the the uh the grief
of of that relationship is
really a major accomplishment I don't
know it's weird because you don't want
to give anything away right
but
people have different takeaways and some
people think it's about
you know parental and kid relationships
and what our parents expect from us but
I love how the character of Cameron he
has this dream
that is
you know really for like actors and
creative people
you know he wants to be an astronaut but
like being an wanting to be an actor or
a comedian
is not that far off from being an
astronaut like people think you're crazy
yeah you're like I want to be an
astronaut you know saying I want to be
an actor you know are you are you from
Indiana I I was gonna say you're
familiar yeah you grew up in it you were
born in Illinois you grew up in Indiana
I grew up in Indiana from the ages of
eight on so yes and I always used to
watch I I never was able to go out I
wasn't popular so I used to watch SNL
and I used to memorize all the skits
sketches and and share them with my
family so I know that's what you did
Growing Up in Indiana too yeah and so
like
if you're from uh
you know if you're in Indiana and you
know it's changed you know but like when
I was growing up if I told people I
wanted to be an actor I'd be like are
you out of your mind oh yeah
it would be the equivalent of saying I
want to be an astronaut yeah so
um
and but I love movies that ask uh that
have that leave you with some questions
you know what I mean and and I loved
acting in uh
uh you know a movie where you don't want
to tip anything you don't want you know
how you know you read the script but
you're like
we want to play
long ball you know I mean and it was so
great working with with uh Ray C horn
because
we knew where it was going
but we also out of respect
for their relationship we didn't want
you know even though they're going
through a a relationship crisis we
didn't want it to be where they
uh you know like the comedic thing would
just be like
they hate each other but they don't
do you know what I mean right it's it's
always explain the opposite it's always
playing against that like they always
say if you have to cry in the scene well
humans as humans we try to do everything
we can not to cry yeah so it's not show
tipping the Hat that's you're exactly
right it's it's far more interesting and
believable and there's a better payoff
when you don't and that's also hard it's
got to be you know the actors have to
know that but also the direction Colin
yeah yeah so I I just I really
thoroughly enjoyed it I really want
people to see linoleum because it's and
not only just see you I really thought
like the casting everything from the
daughter to the boyfriend to the to the
you know the other character that you
played so the old man I couldn't in a
way I think he steals the show without
almost saying anything his eyes
yeah those eyes are just I want to cry
every time I look at him it's just this
sweet man and this this history of what
he wanted in life and the things that he
loved and his memory and I'm not gonna
we're giving it away God they were
tipping our hats no well it's like also
how about Tony salute oh my God yeah
it's like when you see him in the first
scene and then the second scene you're
like oh my God
and that's where I mean
I'm sure you know you know as an actor
like there's these people you work with
and I I did this indie
there's so many moments where I think
all right I'm gonna break through like
there's gonna be this conveyor belt I'll
get led into this room and I'll just get
behanded acting roles and this was like
2004.
and I did this movie
with Tony where he played
um
a work psychiatrist
and he was so amazing and I remember
thinking oh man if I could work with
people like Tony Shalhoub again but like
I don't know if I I don't know if you've
ever worked with him no but he's one of
those like when he he does this yes and
you're uncomfortable yeah he thinks of
every single moment
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs
look if you're thinking of giving you
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge better help can help you be the
best you possible try it today if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside
of you is brought to you by neuro hacker
qualia guys I've been using this for
months and what's funny is I didn't know
they were a sponsor I hadn't read any
spots yet and I was like I guess I
ordered this stuff called qualia neuro
hacker and it was from my mind and it
was like
I need more Focus I need brain fuel uh
and
lo and behold our sponsor neuro hacker
combines 28
of some of the most researched back
nootropic ingredients on earth into an
ultimate brain fuel formula qualia mind
it's been changing people's lives for
years now Ryan
I have noticed that I am just
I'm in a better space I wish that you
could see me in the mornings Ryan
because this is part of my routine
without a doubt you walk in there you're
going to see qualia and I don't like
taking a lot of vitamins and things but
I'm like convinced this works now I'm
not not taking it I have to take this
now
and I because I really think I'm feeling
it uh it's just it's amazing I noticed
the difference in just days Focus uh my
mood my willpower I strongly suggest
this I I'm getting things done I am
writing more for hours on end going oh
my gosh I got my podcast in half an hour
I got to stop writing it's one thing to
another the formula is non-GMO vegan
gluten-free and the ingredients are
meant to complement one another
factoring in each ingredient's effect on
mental Clarity Brian I get asked to
advertise a lot of products and
um I think that the proof of
experiencing something directly
moves moves it right to the top of the
list for me it just makes it easier to
talk about I love when I know what I'm
talking about because I can feel it it's
also backed by a 100 day money back
guarantee so you have almost three
months to try neural hackers quality of
mind at no Financial Risk and decide for
yourself if you deal with brain fog like
me memory lapses sluggish thinking try
neuro hackers qualia mine see what one
of the best brain fuel formulas on Earth
can do for your mindset go to
neurohacker.com IOU for 100 off that's
only thirty nine dollars a bottle and as
The Listener of inside of you use code
IOU at checkout for an extra 15 off your
first purchase that's neurohacker.com
IOU to try neuro hackers qualiamind with
code IOU to experience life-changing
performance these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
and it you didn't play that over over
the top like I was waiting for you to
push it too much like it could become
really comedic but you he's like
reaching his finger to you and you're a
little uncomfortable like I don't want
to be touched without saying it it was
just enough you know what I mean
yeah yeah no it's it's fun but I love
I mean I just uh I just want I want an
opportunity to do more types of
um to do more types of roles like
linoleum yeah like I want to
I I don't you know it's like we've also
kicked around for a while I also I love
the fact that I you know when we had
those shows on TV Land
when I I it was so important for me to
have an opportunity to be
the executive producer and my wife and I
wrote all these things it was so
important for me to have that experience
because
now I know exactly when you're like an
EP and you have to deal with some of the
headaches it's so important to
be that good soldier to be the uh person
that you want to you know because as you
know in the acting world there's people
that are like good people but they're a
pain in the ass oh yeah do you know what
I mean like our friends we have friends
that we like every time you work with
them you're like really this is how
you're gonna behave do you know what I
mean and so like you want to be
the partner you know I describe it as
the good soldier you know the one that
pitches an idea
you know comes with ideas but like if
they don't take the idea it's not the
end of the world yeah yeah like it's
like it's like you're um it's like it's
like these film sets are like you're on
a kibbutz you know what I mean yeah you
want to be on the Cabbage yeah maybe
because I can do the stand-up where I
have absolute control over everything
that I do relish these opportunities to
be on the kibbutz yeah and there's more
of a respect I think too when you become
I think it's it's learned it's not
something that you just are born with I
think through experience you realize
people want to be around people that are
malleable that are just a Cooperative
that will listen to other ideas that
aren't so egocentric and I think there's
a lot that um that comes with that but
you know I've definitely learned like
being an EP means it's not about just
your idea you know you have got to
listen to other people's ideas and
sometimes give in and not be a pain in
the ass and sort of know when to say you
know
um I do want to I want to get into a
little bit of your life because we talk
a lot about Mental Health on this show
and like dealing with life and death and
and and anxiety and depression and on
things that I've dealt with and other
guests have dealt with and
um but before that you know Jason
Patrick who we all love great actor when
I said you worked with Jim say give me
something
yeah and he said when we did that
champion season uh Championship season
on Broadway that his father late father
Jason Miller wrote
you and Jason had a pre-show routine
asking what it was
oh that's so funny
well it was to take uh I mean Jason
Patrick let me set this up to people
that don't know
you know all right so I'm in my 50s are
you in your 50s 50. yeah yeah
there is something about
um there's a last message of
guys in their 50s and let me see if I
can calculate articulate this that
are liberal
open-minded
but they also have kind of this
rap they're they have the last remnants
of the Rat Pack
and of like gaiah stuff and kind of
um
but we you know like you have to
understand that Championship season
which was my first play not even my
first Broadway players my first Christ
that
um and it was it was a play that I had
read I I was pretty much self-educated
uh I studied Finance in college and then
I graduated and I essentially started to
read
I mean I had a minor in English but I I
educated myself on theater and you know
I studied Meisner and all that but
and I love that Championship season and
it really is this analysis of
masculinity and and the 70s and and kind
of race and kind of
I mean it's a really important play yeah
um and um
and it was but are ritual to answer the
question is before the
before we would do the play we would
have a shot of Jameson which is such a
Jason Patrick thing
and I remember thinking I don't want to
do this
I don't want to do this but like if
you've seen the player you read the play
there is like this
there's this and you know like it's been
confused because there's a toxic
masculinity that we're dealing with
today but there is also something about
this
masculine Because by the way in that
play was Jason Patrick Kiefer Sutherland
Ryan Cox Jesus
Chris Noth and me so I was the biggest
[__] of all
and by the way I was a college athlete
you know I mean so it's like and and
these guys had all achieved
incredible success now I would say that
Brian Cox is probably more famous now
yes than he was then but he was
I think he had won an Olivia award by
the way well regarded well regarded yeah
and so
it was so interesting because
um
there was
uh
there was five egos
an incredible play
the playwright's son was in the play
yeah it was on Broadway and when we
would go out and we would start the play
you have to understand this is after 24
was so like 24 was still in people's
memory and Kiefer Sutherland was the
biggest star
it was you know it's pack crowds yeah
packed crowds it was also
when uh
Chris Noth Mr big was still I mean
gigantic and I would say after every
single play every single night we went
out for a drink and often it would end
up
being a mess so we drank like we're in
Cal we drank like those guys Drank in
the play every night so some of it is
like anyone I mean it's great but it's
also one of those things where
people may not realize this it's like
you know actors find the character
within themselves but they there's a
morphing into you become some of that
character and the community becomes that
character uh becomes their characters
and it was uh
it was so interesting because
there's also something of
I don't think that
you know it was the beginning you know
it was I guess 11 years ago
um because I have a son because my wife
was pregnant every day and came to every
performance too
during that one it was the beginning of
um you know there's been different ways
of political correctness but like there
is like the n-word said in this play all
these things
but like
the audience was fine with it but the
critical
even though this play had won the
Pulitzer Prize
um
it was shocking
so it was shocking in that people
couldn't get Beyond some of the language
and so it was we were so knee-deep in it
in understanding that
um this was the language that was used
in Small Town Pennsylvania the the you
know the anti-semitic references it was
it was used it was much more of a
reflection of their insecurities than
being
uh portraying them as racist or
anti-semitic but I think that the
audience and the audience today would
not be able to
separate that right do you understand so
I do
it's it's really interesting and uh
it was so fascinating because you think
of like the the
stardom that these guys had tasted
oh yeah and the stardom that
and the theme that brought people to the
AUD brought people to the show
I think that it was almost a disservice
to the play yeah yeah that's that's my
two cents yeah you know yeah I I
understand that um I know you know he
was very close obviously because his
father had written it and you know it
was an award-winning play and it was
just like I mean there were expectations
and of course and when those
expectations don't aren't met it's sort
of like anything less than you know is
is considered a failure but I think that
it was great as from what I heard and it
was just short-lived
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection you know Jason also
said briefly that you and your wife
Jeannie were two of the biggest
supporters in winning his son Gus back
you headlined a stand up for Gus event
that raised awareness and really started
the movement to get his son back deep
spiritual support and that they love Gus
and that he loves you that's that's
awesome yeah no I mean it is I mean you
know
you know there's so many uh you know
parental alienation and by the way at
that benefit there were a lot of people
there of different
you know there's people that you know
they get divorced and they enter a
same-sex relationship and the other
parent is like then you're out you're I
mean it's the parental alienation thing
it it mainly affects fathers but it can
affect everyone right
and
it is to witness your friend going
through this and to see the cruelty of
it oh my God is uh is pretty staggering
so Jason is really uh and his
relationship with his son is a miracle
but
it's you know it's like it's a crisis on
you know unlike is being the victim of
war or like a physical assault yeah he's
devastated he you know pretty much lost
everything to get his son back I've
gambled everything and gave away it all
for his son yes and he and by the way
the Jason I know
today versus the Jason then
I mean when we say he gave up everything
you you it's not just monetary it's I
mean Jason Patrick was the type of
person who if he was working on a
project and he didn't believe in the art
of it he would bail and now he's in a
position where he's working on projects
that he would probably yell at someone
for pitching the idea absolutely yeah I
mean absolutely that is the journey and
I think that is actually
the beauty of the humility of being a
parent is that
you go through
hell I mean Jason went through a
different type of help but you go
through a process
that uh
it is so it's and I understand why
people don't have kids you know I mean
it's just like
it's you know it's also but like look
why go into a relationship why fall in
love when
someone's going to get their feelings
hurt people are gonna die you know it's
like but you gotta
live a full rich life yeah that's true
I'm still working on that I'm still
single I live alone I have a dog Jim
I'll figure it out but this is not about
me it's about you what was it it's a
German it's a journey what was childhood
like for you I mean did you did you come
from a a good family where you uh were
you happy as a kid I know that at five
you said I want to be an actor but like
uh what was it like growing up as a as a
little gym it was I mean I can tell uh
you know the long story of the short
story you know I mean it's I was the
youngest of six kids
my father was the first one in his
family to go to college we were
many generations uh coal miners
um you know uh
I would say
alcoholism and depressions kind of
littered throughout uh my family
[Music]
um but
I was raised to to seek security and
um security
was uh uh wearing a quote and tie to
work and so
I was a pretty compliant kid like I
thought okay I'll do that you know this
is what you're supposed to do I'll study
finance and I hated it right but I
thought once I got paid I'll like it
and then
um so I think that I was
uh you know
you know I played sports but I think I
did it because my brothers did it you
know I mean I think that
I really didn't kind of figure out or
ask myself what I wanted to be until my
very early 20s
um you know it was I was my I had a job
as a litigation consultant in Tampa and
I remember I had a little micro because
I had written an episode of Miami Vice
I was really
and so I um but I always had dreams
but I didn't know even when I was five I
didn't know anyone in the entertainment
industry like I
in my town there was you know the
marching band but I didn't know uh like
were you you were in Indy right I was in
a small town in Southern Indiana
Newburgh near Evansville which was
borderline almost Henderson Kentucky
oh my god wow that is yes
that's down there yeah and so like I
always thought because like there was no
newscaster Northwest Indiana is a very
much
um
the stepchild to Chicago
um and Indiana in itself has a very
strange identity as you know and so
um
but I think all those things made me who
I am you know I mean I
was born in Illinois
moved to kind of rust belt
uh Indiana then eventually moved to kind
of more on the edge of Ross belt and
farmland so there is something where I
I feel familiar in
white suburbs kind of ethnic uh Ross
belt and farmland things yeah but like
when I was a kid I wanted to be a farmer
wow you know were you popular were you I
was I mean I think that I I mean middle
school was a disaster we had moved right
and it was I went I but high school I
went to a very small high school so I
got very lucky
[Music]
um and but I played Sports I was a
decent athlete but I mean incredible
anxiety like I now know because I have
kids now you know uh you know definitely
some huge anxiety some undiagnosed
learning disabilities but an incredible
Drive I was also
and if a goofy looking kid I was the
whitest kid in an all-white Community
nothing compared to the African-American
experience obviously but like
I was definitely an outsider I was
always an outsider yeah um what kind of
anxiety like how was it just could you
not function was it hard was it always
was it just always present it was um in
middle school I if I talked in Middle
School
I would blush and turn bright red
enough where the teacher would point it
out and say I remember I had a teacher
appointed out and she goes see how his
face is read in anyone else that would
be an indication that he uh is sick or
having a seizure what you know like so
like yeah I mean it was you know like
there was definitely
some bullying that happened from kids or
adults but
I think I also like that's when I kind
of latched on to Comedy was when we
moved uh then
um but I had an older brother who was
pretty good at sports so I I kind of
hung in on Sports but
I would say you know the reason I
started doing stand up
when I moved to New York I got a job in
advertising as an account guy and the
guy who uh and in those settings I would
get really nervous and flustered when I
would speak and so someone suggested I
take improv and so I took Improv
to deal with some of this public
speaking anxiety
and then
um someone dared me to do stand-up I
always wanted to do it but again I
didn't know anyone that did it and I
didn't think it was a realistic thing
and so then when I finally
um then I took kind of like a stand-up
seminar it was just you know
um
and I fell in love with it but like I
had stage fright issues I would say for
the first 10 years of my career like
terrified yeah I know I know what that's
like is is it something that you
eventually got on pills to help you meds
was it something that you just
eventually grew out of and just forced
your way out of anxiety or how did you
do it I think some of it was I I think
some of it was just sheer experience
of doing forcing myself to go on stage
but I think some of it was I grew out of
it
I don't think that
I think I it would have helped if I had
medication you know it would have helped
a lot
but
um
and then I also I think I did a lot of
uh you know therapy I was in group
therapy in my 20s and
I did some work on my stuff you know my
mother died in my early 20s so like
that's really what prompted me
to not just be compliant and do what I
was told to do right is like when she
died the Injustice of her
death she was 53 I was like well then
you know I don't know what I'm you know
supposed to do so that's when I started
um
you know I I did the improv class then I
started doing stand up and I would do
stand up
uh and then I did acting classes after
work and stand up after that and that
was
uh this uh and I did that for like four
or five
years I mean I was definitely I kept my
day job for a long time but I definitely
resigned myself to be
uh the uncle that lives in a tiny
apartment because I had no success
whatsoever I I thought that I was good
but all my peers all my friends were
they were getting sets on Conan or
Letterman and I was not like they would
just leave the room when I would go on
because they had seen me when I was
really bad so they were like he's not
good so so did you want to quit with a
moment were the moments you wanted to
quit I didn't want to quit I just
I had to
come to the realization that
I was not gonna have
a normal success like I was not going to
have monetary
success but I was going to so I or the
acknowledgment of my peer group so
I was like all right I'm just gonna be
this weird guy who does stand up like I
would do stand up at like poetry
readings and stuff like that I was like
this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be
I'm gonna have a day job and I'm gonna
do stand up at night that's that's not
the end of the world or um and so
um
you know once I became comfortable with
I was like and it's weird because
I feel like when I got to
um
you know like the big lie you know like
there's so many moments in my career
where I feel like it's that scene in The
Wizard of Oz where I think
you know you see behind the curtain and
it's like oh this is this is [__]
you know I mean like so like when I
finally got on Letterman and you know
being a a guy from Indiana it was a huge
deal he was a big influence comedically
that I remember and my brother was there
and uh I remember thinking what do I do
now
like it wasn't
like my all this ambition
and then I adjusted in learning that it
was about fulfillment but then I didn't
have anything else in my life right and
so
the ambition kind of
so there's always I mean that's even
kind of goes so like that lesson of
seeking creative fulfillment as corny as
it sounds
is really
an important thing for me so even when
I'm
working on an indie that like when we're
doing linoleum we don't even know if
we're going to be able to finish it but
I was like it's fun to play this
character right
that's more fulfilling than
being in a big broad comedy where
it's fun to do it but it's there's not
it's not that fulfilling does that make
sense yeah you like to be challenged you
like to be in the moment you like to I
mean it just sounds like you know I've
asked this question but like some people
when I ask them do you just love acting
what would you do with that acting and
they're like oh no no that's all I want
to do that's all I love and some people
want to do it because they want fame or
they just do it for money and I
obviously watching you you could see
that you do it because you're already
making a lot of money and you were still
doing these little Indie movies and
still are because you love the craft you
love pushing yourself and especially you
know so that that's what I see
yeah and by the way I mean there is
something and actors all there there's
something about
um I remember making fun because I've
always done
um I've always done Indies and uh or
I've aspired to get in them it's
and I remember the first couple ones I
worked on there were these guys
um you know a man and a woman and they
would talk about their like the big
thing is like they're like I was just I
just wanted to do community theater I
did that's all I wanted to do was come
here and I'm like I don't want to be
dishonest here it's like I mean some of
it is I have a family so I can't really
do community theater
but like I also like that Indies there's
a beginning and an end Jeremy like
I love
um you know I love uh doing interesting
roles but I also
I mean I like the fact that this is uh
linoleum's
went to South by Southwest and I've had
other films at Sundance I'm not you know
like there is some ego in that but like
some of it is
there is something about
the Fulfillment of a role but I don't
I'm not saying like you know what I just
need to be in you know
Michigan doing uh Shakespeare like I'm
not saying that do you know I mean like
oh I know I want to be on yeah I I say
the same thing I say look
I want to do this
how much they pay me I'd like to know
how much they're paying me is there
money involved can we can we make I'd
like to pay for my home my mortgage my
mother right for Christ's sakes yeah
have you ever um
how do you deal with rejection how
what's the and also what's the lowest
you've been you remember a time period
where you hit the lowest and how did you
deal with that
oh my gosh there's been I mean I've had
some pretty humiliating moments um
uh
yeah I mean rejection is
there is a uh
there's so much rejection in the
entertainment industry it's you either
develop calluses
or I mean there is a psychological
impact
uh that I think that
people might not realize like I have a
good friend of mine uh who passed away
and he
was
he he went to an Ivy League school
he went to an Ivy League Law School
he is uh he got a scholarship to a
special high school he was a home run
hitter
and
after and he did stand up and he
had a TV show and he had all this
success but the reality is is with all
that success that he had had through his
life
the amount of rejection that
he dealt with
aft you know like the show was canceled
the agent dumped him you know all this
stuff
I don't think he could process it and he
eventually got into drugs and he died
and the reason I bring that up is that
you know it's not an appetite for
failure or humiliation but you have to
have
it's a pretty tall task these uh these
uh these creative people that are paid
to take things personally to respond
emotionally and authentically they also
have to process all this humiliation so
when someone you know like Kanye West is
a bad example but when some actor loses
their [__] I'm like yeah that's what
they're supposed to do you know I mean
but so it's that maturity
of
dealing with loss and uh disappointment
that makes someone exceptional you know
like Tom Hanks seems like a pretty
amazing guy but there's also
how he's processed the humiliation we
haven't seen is really impressive right
yeah and so but yeah I would say the
lowest point I mean I remember there was
there was a point where
so in the comedy club world again this
is when I was like all my friends were
uh you know getting on uh Conan getting
these measuring points that uh seem to
exist in the stand-up world
and I was getting nothing and I was not
working at some fan at the preeminent
Club because I was a low energy kind of
uh
observational guy that like
did not kind of uh stylistically their
reverence wasn't appealing it wasn't
working at one in the morning right so I
would work I worked at this club I think
it's gone Dangerfield yeah and I would
do a half hour set
and it was brutal it was a total tourist
trap they used to just get people in
there they'd overcharge them and people
would be angry
and so it would be sometimes you'd be
performing for 10 people in this huge
room
and it's kind of hard to understand now
but they're so like sometimes the
audience would be angry so you deal with
these hecklers
and so I dealt with this heckler
um and it was probably a Party of Five
and I was doing commercials but I was
again stand up uh and acting I wasn't
getting at real acting roles and I
wasn't getting stand up and I dealt with
these hecklers the waiters were rude the
bartender was nice but there was just
this one waiter that was kind of a jerk
and I dealt with these hecklers and they
walked out
and then I got off stage and the waiters
like they walked out on their check you
have to pay their check
and I was kind of in like so then I had
to pay for these people that were total
jerks to me I had to pay for their tab
and I remember thinking
this is like a level of humiliation that
I mean it was on top of
all this other stuff that had been you
know just I couldn't get an agent I was
making this agency tons of money in
commercials but I couldn't get an agent
and I didn't know that I could have left
and gone to another agency and said hey
I want to get
you know some of it is but it just
looked very dark and I was like what am
I doing and I remember that was
a pretty low point when I was just
taking the subway home it was just
humiliation like I'm literally losing
money
after doing this for eight years you
know I mean so yeah
there was definitely those
low points you could have easily walked
away a lot of people just said okay
enough's enough I'm gonna I think about
my dad I'm gonna get a suit and tie I'm
gonna go get a job I'm not gonna do this
anymore I'm not going to suffer I
remember there's walks too I remember
I remember those walks thinking remember
this walk
you know while you're walking and you're
just staring at a light for five minutes
and you're just like not really there
but you're there it's almost this
numbing feeling of what am I doing what
am I gonna do I'm it's scary I don't you
know it's uh yeah yeah we know like
insanity is repeatingly doing something
and expecting a different outcome right
right right right right right like
you're doing that it's with the reality
of
oh I'm insane so that was you know I
definitely
I mean everyone in my family thought I
was crazy but like I was like now I'm
like oh I am crazy yeah I mean it's
and it was also
you know I was very driven it was not
I was kind of you know you work hard you
get results none of that was strong and
by the way that is not
you know understanding the entertainment
industry is
is really a pointless Adventure right
because it's it's fluid you know like
even like when Kanye says these horrible
things about the entertainment industry
it's like
there's no Grand conspiracy dear I mean
it's just unfair do you know what I mean
yeah it's just people doing there's no
one out to get anyone you know I mean
it's like come on yeah
when was the moment you said
holy [__] was it was it the Lettermen
finally being on Letterman was it you
know your first special was it your
first book you know what was the what
was that moment where you thought
you [__] did it Jim you [__] went
against the grain you did it your own
way here you are
and you said hey and you could
appreciate what you had done and really
um kind of just said
nice job
I mean there was uh
there was a couple moments
it's I mean Letterman was
like I remember thinking okay I can
because you know what
in that era
and and as an actor or a comedian
when you would tell people
you're an actor or comedian
they'd be like have you been on anything
and if you had nothing to say they would
look at you like
um and so I knew once I did Letterman
I had won that argument so I was a real
comedian that that was a measuring stick
there was my personal measuring stick
and the measuring stick that I
encountered like people used to be like
you should go on The Tonight Show it's
like it's not like I haven't thought of
it right
but I would say that there's moments
where
I mean I'm sure it's the same for you
like there's moments where
I also
I don't whenever you think you got to
figure it out you don't you're I mean
it's so but I would say that there are
moments where I'm like oh wow this is
nice like for me I felt like
you know I mean I even feel like when
Dave Attell told me he thought I was
funny like that's a huge thing that was
a long time ago too wasn't it yeah and
then like doing Dr Katz I was like oh
that's actually a show I want to watch
yeah and
but I think there was also
um you know when I was it's so funny
because like I uh
I was doing stand up and I had had
different managers and
um you know like there's no rules for
like managing a career I remember I was
talking to
Ed Helms about this he's like there's no
internship on how to deal with like oh
you're and it's not about money it's
about like oh here's what you should do
because there's no
no one's had the exact same experience
but there's
there's a moment where
um
I remember I was touring doing stand-up
again I had a lot of
uh you know I had done Welcome to New
York I had done the Allen Show I had you
know like the acting the stand the
sitcom acting thing
it's it's weird because like
the
again it's like what happens in my life
I feel like this is a therapy session
what it is
what what happens in my life is
I have to learn things over and over
again and so the one of the things I
constantly fall into the Trap of is
getting caught up in other people's
expectations yeah so
in my
parents expectations nothing malicious
but they're like success is wearing a
coat and tie so I spent up until my 20s
success is wearing a coat and tie I'm
going to do that I'm going to work coat
and tie that's how you get happy right
and so
the whole thing is is when I did
Letterman and then I got Welcome to New
York and then I got on Ellen uh the
Ellen second show
I was
doing the sitcom route and then I was on
That 70s Show and Ed I did we occurred
on Ed and I remember thinking
like even You Know That 70s Show was so
big at the time but I remember thinking
well this isn't that fun like I've had
like you know hear me out so it's like
the four camera sitcom experience
was not that fun from an acting like I
had other acting experiences in Indies
or in other things where I was like why
is
the uh the acting on sitcoms why isn't
that as fun as the other thing but so
then I was like
oh it's television
I I don't want to do television so then
I was like
I'm not doing television and so then I
did that Championship season
and I thought I learned
um
and and some of it was Kiefer was like
you need to be in charge of your own
show that's the thing
and so then my wife and I did the Jim
Gaffigan show and it was it was great
it's a lot of work like an enormous
amount of work
and so I said
all right what I like is acting
but I like
dealing with complex characters where I
like being part of a team I don't want
to be in charge of the team
I want to be I want to uh you know like
the whole director or executive producer
thing that's a lot I mean I don't have
the energy for that yeah and so but I
like being a partner and so I eventually
learned oh yeah it's these these Indies
the films they have a beginning and an
end
there's a collaborative thing you know
the smaller they are the the more
Community it is you know what I mean and
that you're all kind of there for the
right reasons
and so
[Music]
um
but like other people's expectations
that's where I keep getting that's where
I fall down it's like oh yeah you know
you should want to be in a Marvel movie
I'm like should I maybe I should do I
want to be in a Marvel and it's and by
the way there's I don't have anything
against those movies but I do know
that
doing linoleum or American dreamer or
some of these other Indies
it is fun you know what I mean I think
because it's more challenging I don't
even know how I started on this it's all
right we'll cut it all out no I'm
kidding it was great it makes perfect
sense listen this is called [__] talking
with Jim Gaffigan uh these are my top
tier patrons that get to ask it's rapid
fire you just ask to answer the
questions you have a lot of insight I
like this it's digging in kind of seeing
what makes you tick and how you've I
like the journey I love this [__] this
is what the the listeners like Miss
Kayla Sue what has been your biggest
help balancing a successful career
marriage and five kids and being a
producing partner with your wife which
most people would probably be divorced
if they were producing and writing
Partners yeah well what I would say is
that you know the joke is that I do it
very poorly but I would say that it's a
constant evaluation and
it's um
you know it's like you you also have to
understand it's like my wife
is was kind of is my writing partner
right so but like when she has a brain
tumor or she's writing a book or we're
dealing with essentially five kids that
are like teenagers it's like how much
writing
should even be the priority you know I
mean or should I you know uh relish the
access that I get to it that I do
um but it is I would say the answer to
that
it's a constant evaluation every three
months I mean it's ongoing where my
wife's like you know every script I uh
you know she reads everything that I'm
gonna do and she'll be like this is not
worth it
this is not worth it and I'll be like
all right you know I mean it's yeah it's
a partnership and she's usually right
do you you don't yeah you don't seem
like someone it's always good to have
someone like that in your life whether
it's a friend your wife someone who can
say [__] off Jim someone could say Jim
this is not what you want to do
just be that voice of reason because if
not we're like again we listen to We
want to fulfill our agents expectations
and make them happy okay okay you tend
to do that that's what we do we want to
make people happy
um I don't ever see you as someone who
snaps are you someone that can really be
scary when you do snap can you just be
like intense and be like no we're not
doing that
oh yeah no I can be a dick you can be a
dick yeah totally no I mean I um
yeah I mean it's
yeah it's it's you know there's uh
there's the decision I mean I almost
want to go back to the the you know to
the previous question because like here
let me ask you let me answer it this way
okay well you have to understand is also
when my wife had her brain tumor
there was
an expectation that I was done with
touring I was done with acting
my life you know I was going to be the
single father of five children I wasn't
gonna Outsource it
so
when she made it through
there was
oh my gosh I can do this a greater
appreciation for stand-up and acting
but
the answer is still the same it's still
every three months or every project is
this worth
um
being away you know what I mean or or
um that's like even shows in La I've
never done I you know I turned down all
shows like TV shows in LA and you know I
know you've spent time in Vancouver I
did Peter Pan in Vancouver for four
months during the pandemic where I
couldn't leave
and so like but that's Disney and my
wife was like yeah that's Disney you're
going to do that but like it would I go
up there and do a show for four months I
don't know I don't think I would right
you know what I mean yeah uh little Lisa
what's your most prized possession and
why that's a tough question I don't know
how you answer that one
yeah that's that's really hard price
possession I don't know I mean I think
um
I I just feel so grateful that
that I have different creative Outlets
because
I love acting but if I relied solely on
acting for Creative fulfillment I would
lose my mind because you don't get to do
it enough
and you're beholden to again it's not
malicious Too Many Factors you know what
I mean yeah you're like I want that role
no no you don't get it whereas in stand
up I can write something try it that
night CBS Sunday commentaries I get a
little fulfillment out of the you know I
get the Fulfillment from that you know
it's nice when's your next tour
I'm always touring kind of always going
on I'm uh
I'm taping a special in uh uh Tampa in
mid-February
[Music]
um
what's what streaming platform will that
be on
I think Netflix I you know it's
with going back to our initial
conversation I don't know where these
streamers are you know I mean it's like
you know
um
you know this will be my 10th comedy
special I don't know
I mean I didn't know that I would do one
comedy special but uh it is also really
fun and rewarding that process yeah I
mean you do all these things it's like
you know you're the voice of Van Helsing
Hotel Transylvania and like these are
cool things that I've always wanted to
do and people always because you do a
lot of voice and you write books and is
it something you get do you just get
bored and go I want to try something
different oh I'll be successful as an
author I got bored I'm gonna be because
you do so many things and you're
successful at them it's sort of like you
know what can't you do or is there
something you want to do
what would you do what else would you
want to do
I mean there is
I just think that like directing that
that's too much that's too much work
it's a lot yeah I mean yeah I mean I do
I did want to uh
write a book but I think it's again
that's I I don't want to get caught up
in other people's expectations I just
want to
that creative fulfillment I want to I
mean I definitely would love to play
um a variety of different characters you
know I mean like I want to you know
there's all these voices in my head I
want them to have life they will they
absolutely will look uh we're gonna
finish this but like you know a few
years ago you were the most popular
comic on Pandora with
647 million spins I don't even know how
that's possible dude uh that it's
remarkable and you have millions of
followers uh you were 25 funniest people
on Twitter you're like one of the top
comics every year you're hilarious you
stick to your guns you do you know a lot
of people will go to dirty comedy and
very uh you know you stick to what you
do and you don't stray and that to me is
incredible on its own because even back
then when things weren't going the way
you wanted I'm sure you thought well
maybe I should I need a few more f-bombs
in here you know no it's like it's
yeah I mean authenticity a personal
authenticity not is
it's you know it takes a while
for people to you know know themselves
you know I mean and it's ongoing that's
what's also so amazing about stand up is
you know you're learning more about
yourself and
you're also I mean this stuff this
special in this tour I'm much more
sarcastic uh and
probably darker you know than I have
been but
but that's what's also I think so fun
about stand up is the relationship you
have with an audience it is a friendship
and you have to challenge what we love
about conversations with friends is that
it's never the same conversation yeah I
mean yeah do you ever uh on stage while
you're doing a special doing stand-up
really crack yourself up like because
it's it's routine you know the routine
but does something ever get you where
you just can't stop laughing and not
can't stop laughing but there is
something about
and I would say there are what's so
there there's a lot of moments on stage
particularly when you're developing
uh topic or a joke where words come out
of your mouth that
you didn't plan on right you know what I
mean where
and some of that it's like the audience
should get a writing credit really you
know I mean it's
it's kind of like it kind of comes out
that's why I
uh you know it is so fun and so
rewarding there is just lightning strike
and sometimes it's a tag sometimes it's
which is just like a joke a line after a
joke but there's you know there is some
kind of
stuff that happens on stage so it is
written but it's there's a lot of
moments in that written that just came
out do you still get nervous yeah I
think uh not as not as dramatically
nervous as I used to be but yeah if I
wasn't a little nervous
I'd be in trouble and some of it is
because I'm always working on new stuff
you know there's an unspoken agreement
that if people are coming to a show of
stand-up that it's new material so right
yeah uh linoleum is the movie I watched
this movie at eight this morning
and freaking loved it uh if you haven't
seen Jim Gaffigan in a dramatic role and
he's done some dramatic roles you're
going to be just blown away by this I
really am proud of you I'm happy for you
I I love that you're doing what you do
what you love and uh you know you're a
family man and you've stuck to your guns
and you deserve all the success man so
linoleum it's are you going to the Palm
Springs is that where you're at now I'm
here right now yeah and if you already
screened it
no tonight are you nervous
[Laughter]
I mean we've had it at a couple
festivals people like it it's uh
yeah so it's it's exciting I love it
it's touching it's mysterious thought
provoking you guys are gonna love this
look for it and at Jim Gaffigan is that
your handle yes yes follow this man
watch his specials read his books and
linoleum is awesome thanks for finally
coming on man I really had a good time
with you I'm glad this worked out thank
you so much too all right take care Jim
take care see ya bye
well there you go
he's been around for a while it's crazy
how big he's gotten yeah and he doesn't
do the dirty stuff as a comedian I don't
mean like a size this person but yeah
all right yeah he's but uh no he's huge
and uh just by being himself and he's um
garnered a following and he's able to do
these cool movies
yeah it's cool life I think this is a
cool life and he's doing it all you know
between writing and producing and
um acting and the comedy and having a
family is like you know you always say
how do these people navigate how do they
sort of balance and I'm sure it's not
easy at all
and I look around I'm like how do I
even function
doing one thing but uh hey I appreciate
you guys listening and again uh if you
want to join patreon to support the
podcast patreon.com uh inside of you
uh I would love if you joined and I will
respond to you eventually on there and
um I'll you'll definitely become a
somebody will know we give shout outs to
patrons and uh
what else head over to the inside of you
online store to get some awesome merch
autograph merch ship Keys leximus
scripts uh lunch boxes and a bunch of
other cool stuff like tumblers and
whatnot I've given most of my free [__]
to Ryan
and um so I have enough tumblers yeah
there you have it you've got enough
tumblers I think you have a tumbler from
I mean you know you do uh that's really
it I just want to give the shout outs to
these top tier
um patrons and uh just want to tell you
I appreciate you listening and hopefully
you'll be back next week we're going to
try and bring the great guests to you
doing my best and hopefully you are so
here we go
Nancy D Leah asks Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie M Kristen K Raj C Joshua
D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike E Aldon Supremo 99 more Santiago M
Chad W Leanne P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray
tab of the T Tom and correct Liliana hey
correct Talia M Betsy D Chad L Dan and
big Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon Corey K
Dev Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Camille
s correct Joni B
Joey m eugenan
Leah Corey Heather L Jake B Megan T
Angel F Mel c s s Orlando
C correct Carolina Christine s Eric H sh
Shane r m r Andrew M Z oichi 77 Andreas
Andreas n Oracle Karina and Amanda R Jen
B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel Billy s jam
and Jay Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F
Stone H Miss s Brian L kdb Aaron B Aaron
R Aaron R Kendall L House of Joe L
Meredith I and Charlene C
those are the top tier paw patrons I
can't do it without you and we just did
a um
live YouTube with all the patrons it was
great I played music and we talked and
it was they asked me questions and
that's another perk and
I have to do a big you know I have to do
with my talk to your patrons again soon
is a um
a zoom with all of them oh so sometimes
they do that
and it's fun so it's a good time
um that's about it Ryan you got anything
uh not today no no
well that's it really yeah we had a
great guest today that we interviewed it
wasn't the one that aired obviously Jim
Gaffigan was great they've all been good
honestly all the recent ones yeah I
think they're uh they're good I just
hope people tune in even if they don't
know the a person or care about the
person I mean if you hate the person I
think you should listen anyway because
you might like them after there's one
coming up that I'm looking forward to
that we both got a lot out of
if you could think of guy or girl uh a
female person actually
that was good there's a lot of them yeah
there's a lot I don't want to say it
because you give it away all right we're
excited we love you uh from the
Hollywood Hills in uh Hollywood
California I am Michael Rosenbaum I am
right is here at the Halloween we love
you guys uh please be good to yourselves
and uh we'll see you next week
[Music]